if you guys have wondered what it's like
to wake up next to Kody this is exactly
it
next to me well not next sorry that was
that was weird
I mean he's this Christ if you ever
wonder what it's like to wake Kody up
from his bunk in the tour bus this is
exactly what he's like it actually I
mean already it looks like it's a sleep
mask yeah I was laughing I was like this
is this is Kody in the morning you know
what's sheikh about a silly mask is that
when you wake up in the morning you look
Apolo Ohno that cuz he's sick as [ __ ]
but number two if you got hair like mine
you can it's it's dual use you can use
it as a headband for the whole morning
yeah and so you just rock it up here and
you look dope you field oh yeah and
third of all it's fast you all it's
fashionable yeah hard oh that's kind of
number one but whatever this is Matthew
McConaughey just waking up this is dude
this dude ever ever leave character no
no you can't possibly be like no just
let it just let it ride it gets even
better do you think he's perpetually
just thinks he's in a movie I think he's
been in front of cameras so long that
he's just lost that's what I'm saying
it's like in The Truman Show mm-hmm he
does everything he thinks there's like
an A and a B cam yep everywhere he goes
he I just think that but to be that
level of actor I think you just you're
never not performing yeah I think you'd
like you said I mean it's not so much
like leaving character he's practicing
always yeah you know I just think he has
a natural like okay go ahead and he's
you know when I was seven I wrote a
little Radio Flyer
just like that and the whole room was
like oh like you know you know he's
gonna be a [ __ ] awesome dad though
mm-hmm cuz that's what good you know I'm
saying good dads well I mean like when
you're a kid you want to hear weird
stories like that or like this inspiring
you know yeah you know he's a teacher
now what yeah he's teaching part-time or
something
what my teachers at a school that that
could be totally wrong but let's see
Matthew McConaughey teacher uh yeah
University of Texas he teaches college
kids yeah about what how to act he is
teaching script to screen course yeah
since 20 2015 okay maybe this is like a
1:1 off things he's been doing it for a
while anyway let's keep going classic
come on just wait this jet lag just wait
okay just wait it gets even better
okay you have to get this part you have
to get this what the [ __ ] oh now we got
now the [ __ ] [ __ ] damn it it like
hit HD right at the end yet yeah it's an
the glass of whiskey that's what yeah in
diesel jeans jeans yes the same [ __ ]
it's exactly the same uh-huh welcome to
jet lag baby so now that I'm wide awake
it's time for a sip of longneck is that
his whiskey no it's like um
Wild Turkey hold on Long Branch sipping
Long Branch damn he looks strong out in
that yeah holy that's like that brendan
fraiser red eyes just looking
top comment wait for it this is like
bugging somebody's why is this hot dude
I feel like someone I feel like someone
got this from like an alcoholic uncle or
something like that yeah that video you
know just learn how to use his iPad
what's up yeah what's up Carly checking
in I'm out here in London London
I don't thought I slept 10 hours turns
out I've been asleep forever in 22
minutes it's Ned I'm wide awake it's
time for the super long range in a pork
cracklin
is that a pork rind is that the same as
a pork rind a pork cracklin I think is
like a pork skin got it okay
pork cracklin that's what our that's
what I refer to my forehead as pork
cracklin pork cracklin yeah pork
cracklin is pork crackling god damn it
oh man that's when we have a dope bit
yeah on the podcast yeah pork crackling
it
it's crackled pork that was a pork
crackling yeah yeah like who is that
who's that video it's like I don't talk
to him for like years and then he'll
just [ __ ] send me a video like this
right he's got big cousin energy yeah
Matt McConaughey yeah Bry just like like
everything about this man like is he is
he sitting did he did he literally just
wake up does he have does he have long
branch bedside table where did he get
this cup this cup is dumb fancy no it
might not be though it might be just be
plastic that's what it looks like to me
what a shitty party cup it is but I'm
saying like it's still fancy party cup
how much is that I can't tell is it a
shot or is it a whole glass you know the
guy right hammering he's making it the
perspective is got it so [ __ ] up yeah
is he just like a giant holding like a
beer keg you know see a giant something
kind of beers a pint he's so big and
he's just like paint
it has two fingers branch bro
fee-fi-fo-fum whose pork cracklin is
going in my tongue oh my god this is so
funny okay where is he is he in bed
still it's what I mean is what is this
room this is this is this is like a self
tape before murdering someone man I just
as it is this looks like an evidence
video yeah it looks like some [ __ ]
they'd find yeah
you